et yann vous vous n'en pouvez plus du
confinement et des mesures plus strictes
vous dites que ça suffit on va en parler
avec vous mais juste avant voulait avoir
une image qui a beaucoup fait parler
c'était chez pascal praud où vous
expliquer votre colère face à la
fermeture des librairies et vous alliez
plus loin puisque certains ont cru que
vous appeliez à désobéir garde
désobéissance civique est un devoir et
je crois qu'en ce moment
moi je m'apprête à désobéir civiquement
aux consignes mais je vais arrêter
je vais arrêter nous confiner je vais
arrêter de remplir les fiches qui vaut
pour sortir je tairai toutes les amendes
je suis même d'accord pour payer les
amendes des libraires qui voudraient
ouvrir leur librairie
je crois que de temps en temps il est un
il est un devoir de liberté individuelle
que de désobéir à des à des décisions
qui nous semble absurde
ben est inique inintelligente et jamais
elle a désobéissants feeling croiser les
doigts et on pouvait ne pas avoir
d'histoire
alors c'était un coup de colère qui
était alors il ya des gens qui vous a
police à regarder des gens chez jeudi
pour ça pourquoi parce que cyril les
libraires sont des gens extrêmement
courageux peut-être que tout le monde ne
rentre pas dans une librairie mais
symboliquement j'ai trouvé extrêmement
désagréable et même violent que ce qui
fait l'honneur de la france c'est à dire
la librairie libre et vous savez dont il
ya beaucoup de pays dans le monde on
sent pas très bien quand on arrive vous
allez à los angeles par exemple il ya
plus librairie et je trouve que
symboliquement même si on ne rentre pas
savoir que les libraires assure une
sorte de permanence contre le virus
comme des biens des permanences aussi
caricaturale contre l'intégrisme et le
terrorisme
et là il y avait une sorte de permanence
morale et intellectuelle qui voulait
dire que le pays de la littérature le
pays des livres
il tenait quand même debout dans des
circonstances qui était extrêmement
désagréable mais pour je vais vous
rappeler à eau les gens à sortir quand
je parlais de désobéissance j'appelais
en fait les libraires désobéir d'accord
lorsque je trouve que c'est pas
essentiel un livre c'est vital et
psychologiquement savoir qu'on peut
aller acheter un livre est un livre ou
même faire un tour dans une prairie moi
qui ne vais pas à l'église
ni dans une mosquée ni dans une
synagogue le l'endroit où j'ai trouvé la
foi si vous laisser dans les librairies
aussi sait où on en a parlé il ya
quelques jours c'est encore yann moix
quelqu'un qui prêche pour sa paroisse et
je le comprends c'est ce qu'il fait
bouffer mais aujourd'hui je trouve sage
à ma connaissance
yann n'est pas épidémiologistes ni
médecin il n'est pas non plus au
gouvernement et il me semble pas
essentiel je pourrais dire la même chose
sur le théâtre j'ai envie de jouer au
théâtre la culture c'est vital non la
culture c'est pas vital ce qui est vital
en ce moment c'est de protéger les gens
qui sont sensibles et dont on fait
peut-être partie c'est de protéger nos
aïeux nos enfants c'est de protéger la
france entière et d'être solidaire parce
que pour une fois
moi j'en appelle à la vraie solidarité
celle qu'on nous réclame en permanence
la bonne charité chrétienne comme bien
essayé de l'expliquer tout à l'heure
pour noël ce serait bien qu'on soit pas
le non plus dans le consumérisme et
surtout pas pour sa propre paroisse et
il me semble que c'est très important en
ce moment que les gens qui doit fermer
qui accueillent du public ferme
tant pis si on bouffe un peu moins bien
on va bouffer un peu moins bien c'est
une certitude mais la culture bas
survivrait des livres en l'occurrence on
a chez soi j'invite d'ailleurs les gens
à relire tous les grands auteurs
français ça m'étonnerait qu'ils les
connaissent tous par coeur et dans une
bibliothèque on a les moyens de vivre
puisque 6 6 7 6 me tall que ça voilà ce
qui me choque en ce moment on n'a pas le
rac de promener en forêt par contre les
chasseurs ont le droit c'est à dire que
si vous êtes armé vous avez le droit
c'est fou mais si vous voulez avec votre
gauche
aller dans la forêt d'à côté vous pouvez
pas 1 500 vient d'annuler les paladins
populaire et bien de l'annuler voilà
donc s'il l'avait autorisée c'était jean
michel maire voulait réagir
je suis d'accord avec avec philippe
parce que c'est un combat
d'intellectuels je dis pas de gauche
mais de ça mau combat les livres
évidemment mais enfin pourquoi une
librairie a plus le droit de survivre
qu'à serrurier qu'un mec n'a rien d'un
pressing quelques chats si si quelqu'un
m'offre tout le monde va morfler moi je
suis bon taux pour la fermeture des
grandes surfaces pour les petits
commerçants à tous restent ouverts et
que les grandes surfaces ont les reins
solides puis ceux ci me tenir avec les
gros fonds qu'ils ont les freins tabassé
au dos et qu'on laisse ces petits
commerces ouverts envers les chercheurs
je suis d'accord avec yann sur le côté
il faut sauver les libres et il faut
sauver le petit commerce mais venant
d'un intellectuel comme vous qui en plus
peut être précepteur le mot
désobéissance me choque
oui il devait nommer jan ce n'est pas au
dessus des lois non non vous deux
nous devons je dois obéir aux lois et on
peut contester les lois il faut se
mobiliser sans doute pour que le petit
commerce soit sauvée mais pas en
contestant sa mère les gens vont sortir
urgence quand je danse je fais comme
yann moix et on jouera sur c'est pour ça
que j'ai précisé immédiatement
les règles les j'obéis aux règles je
suis légaliste pas légitimisme et
légaliste et donc j'ai toujours mis mon
masque je chronomètre mais prenant
d'extra si le message doit être celui là
il faut le dire
j'entends tout ce que vous dites et je
suis d'accord avec tout ce que vous
dites le problème de ces mesures ne sont
pas qu'elle existe c'est qu'on a
l'impression que les règles du jeu
changent de manière presque aléatoire et
arbitraire tous les jours et que il
réinvente les règles à mesure que les
semaines passent et à une règle édictée
une bonne fois pour toute c'est quelque
chose de bien parce qu'on peut
s'installer dans une cohérence
mais comme on a l'impression que même ne
savent pas parce qu'il part oubli et
peut-être aussi parfois par incompétence
ce qui doit être essentielle ou pas
évidemment on se retrouve dans des
situations il n'y a que des cas
d'exception et qu' on n'est que dans le
cas par cas on a voulu faire quelque
chose alors général et finalement on se
retrouve dans une montagne de cas par
cas et chacun effectivement pas ce que
c'est qu'un prêt je parte se porte juste